what i'm also fascinated by is metrics
that are different than engagement
so the other thing from an alien
perspective
what social networks are doing
is they um
they in the short term bring out
different aspects of each human being so
first let me say
that
an algorithm or a social network
for each individual can bring out the
best of that person or the worst of that
person or there's a bunch of different
parts to us parts we're proud of
that
that we are parts we're not so proud of
when we look at the big picture of our
lives when we look back 30 days from now
am i proud that i said those things or
not am i proud that i felt those things
am i proud that i experienced or read
those things or thought about those
things just in that kind of
self-reflective kind of way
and so coupled with that i wonder if
it's possible to have different metrics
they're not just about engagement
but are about
long-term happiness
growth of a human being where they look
back and say
i am a better human being for having
spent 100 hours on that app
and
that feels like it's actually strongly
correlated with engagement
in the long term in the short term it
may not be but in the long term it's
like the same kind of thing
where you really fall in love with the
product
you fall in love with an iphone you fall
in love with the car
that's what makes you fall in love is
like
really
being proud
and just
in a self-reflective way understanding
that you're a better human being for
having used the thing and that's like
where the f
that's what great relationships are made
from it's not just like you're hot
and we like being together or something
like that it's more like i'm a better
human being because i'm with you
and that feels like a metric that could
be optimized for by the algorithms
um but you know anytime i kind of talk
about this with anybody they seem to say
yeah okay that's going to get out
competed immediately by the engagement
if it's ad driven especially
i just don't think so
i don't i i mean um
a lot of it's just implementation i'll
say a couple of things one is to
pull back the curtain on daily meetings
inside of these large social media
companies
a lot of what
management or or at least the people
that are are tweaking these algorithms
spend their time on our trade-offs
and there's these things called value
functions which are like okay
we can predict the probability that
you'll click on this thing or the
probability that you'll share it
or the probability that you will leave a
comment on it or the probability
you'll dwell on it
individual actions right
and you've got this neural network that
basically has a bunch of heads at the
end and all of them are between 0 and 1
and great they all have values right or
or they all have probabilities
um
and then in these meetings what they
will do is say well uh
how much do we value a comment versus a
click versus a share versus a
and then maybe even some downstream
thing right that has nothing to do with
the item there but like
driving follows or something
and what typically happens is they will
say well what are our goals for this
quarter at the company oh we want to
drive sharing up okay well let's uh turn
down these metrics and turn up these
metrics
and and they blend them right into a
single scaler with which they're trying
to optimize
that is really hard because invariably
you think you're solving for i don't
know something called meaningful
interactions right
this was the big facebook pivot and i i
don't actually have any internal
knowledge like i wasn't in those
meetings
but at least from from what we've seen
over the last month or so it seems by
actually trying to trying to optimize
for meaningful interactions it had all
these side effects of optimizing for
these other things um and i don't claim
to fully understand
them but what i will say
is that trade-offs abound
and as much as you'd like to solve for
one thing if you have a network of over
a billion people
you're gonna have unintended
consequences either way and it gets
really hard so what you're describing is
effectively a value model that says like
can we capture this is the thing that i
spent a lot of time thinking about like
can you capture
utility
in a way that like actually measures
someone's happiness
that isn't just a um
what do they call it a surrogate problem
where you say well i kind of think like
the more you use the product
the happier you are that was always the
argument at facebook by the way it was
like well people use it more so they
must be more happy yeah turns out
they're like a lot of things you use
more that make you less happy in the
world not talking about facebook just
you know let's think about
whether it's gambling or whatever like
that you can do more of but doesn't
necessarily make you happier so the idea
that time equals happiness obviously
you can't map utility and time together
easily there are a lot of edge cases
so when you look around the world and
you say well what are all the ways we
can model utility that's like one of the
please if you know someone smart doing
this introduce me because i'm fascinated
by it and it seems really tough
but the idea that reinforcement learning
like everyone interesting i know in
machine learning like i was really
interested in recommender systems and
supervised learning and
and the more i dug into it i was like oh
literally everyone smart is working on
reinforcement learning
like literally everyone you just made
people at open ai and deep mind very
happy yes but i mean but what's
interesting is like it's one thing to
train a game and like
i mean that paper that where they just
took atari and they used a convnet to
basically just like train simple actions
mind-blowing right absolutely
mind-blowing but it's a game great
so now what if you're constructing
a feed for a person right
like
how can you
construct that feed in such a way
that optimizes for a diversity of
experience a
a long-term happiness right
but that reward function it turns out in
reinforcement learning again
as i've learned
like reward design is really hard
and
i don't know like how do you design a
scalar reward for someone's happiness
over time i mean do you have to measure
dopamine levels like do you have to well
you have to have a lot of
a lot more signals from the human being
currently it feels like there's not
enough signals coming from the human
being users of uh
of this algorithm so for reinforcement
learning to work well
it needs to have a lot more data
it needs to have a lot of data and that
actually is a challenge for anyone who
wants to start something which is you
don't have a lot of data so how do you
compete but i do think back to your
original point rethinking the algorithm
rethinking reward functions rethinking
utility that's fascinating that's cool
and i think that's an open opportunity
for
for a company that figures it out
you